on nous fait miroiter qu'il y aura un
projet hybride au centre on dire que
quand on va passer au tout végétal et
qu'on va se faire mettre dehors et part
avancé le sud ouest est rayé de la carte
au niveau 2 au niveau de l'entreprise
d'un homme tout simplement
[Musique]
ans
en
[Musique]
nous on se retrouve dans le flou pendant
on est viré à fin décembre et donc on a
tout un droit au travail de
reconstruction avec notre notre
fournisseur est bon c'est sûr que
l'incertitude pour nous c'est pas
terrible j'aurais pu essayer peut-être
de nous regarder à nouveau tant que
producteur même si l'envié revit de ne
plus produire des yaourts sont aussi
on fait de la vente directe mais cela
dit si on n'a pas attendu pour valoriser
on ne peut pas continuer cet atelier
donc ça va bien en cause aussi la
cueillir financier de mon exploitation
le manque à gagner serait
crs à faire des 70000 euros par an
[Musique]
on
on a beaucoup de d'emploi qui
proviennent de studen danone est donc là
déjà entendu parler d'une quarantaine
d'emplois menacés des départs à la
retraite anticipée qui seront pas
remplacés donc pour forcément des jeunes
qui pourront pas démarrer dans la vie
active est ici dans les territoires
ruraux comme les nôtres eh bien ce sera
un des gros gros impact que ce soit donc
pour le côté producteurs pour le côté
emploi
[Musique]